Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen, wie breit mein Grinsen ist, denn Christian Bernhard sitzt endlich wieder neben mir. Wir wollen über die Serie A sprechen. Mein Gott, es wurde wirklich Zeit. Jetzt endlich Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 143. Bernie, es ist so schön, dass du wieder hier bist.
Hallo Max, wunderschön bei dir zu sein.
Ach, das wird Jubisszenen geben, wenn das hier in den Podcatchern der Leute landet. Ich sage es dir, da wird es spontan Feuerwerk geben, Feinstaubbelastung geht durch die Decke in Deutschland. Weil die Leute sich freuen, sie haben gefordert. Christian Bernhard zurück in den Rasenfunk, haben sie ernsthaft. Du kriegst es ja immer nicht mit, aber haben sie wirklich. Und jetzt ist es soweit.
Und jetzt sind wir hier.
Jetzt sind wir hier und reden über die Serie A, über die wir schon so lange nicht gesprochen haben und von der ich tatsächlich nicht so viel mitbekommen habe in den letzten Monaten. Wenn ich mir allerdings die Tabelle angucke, dann gibt es die eine konstante Juve auf Platz 1. Aber was sehe ich denn da? Eine Niederlage am vergangenen Wochenende. Und aus zuverlässiger Quellen, nämlich von dir, weiß ich, dass du dich mit dem Spiel gegen Napoli beschäftigt hast. Was war da los?
Ja, da war los, dass Napoli endlich wieder mal, Gott sei Dank, das gezeigt hat, was sie eigentlich können, aber was sie in den letzten Wochen sehr gut versteckt haben. Das war wirklich ein sehr intensives Spiel. Toll von Napoli, schwach von Juve, keine Frage. Ich würde aber in dem Fall sagen, dass es noch ein Tick mehr dran lag, dass das Napoli sehr, sehr gut gemacht hat. Sie haben sehr aggressiv gegen den Ball, gut defensiv gestanden. Und dann in der zweiten Hälfte haben sie ihre Chancen genutzt. Von Juve kam wirklich sehr, sehr wenig offensiv. Deswegen hat dann auch das achte Ligaspieltor in Serie von Cristiano Ronaldo zum achtmal in Serie getroffen. Aber völlig verdient die Niederlage aus Juversicht oder verdient der Napolisieg.
Okay, lass mal erst über Napoli sprechen, weil wir fangen sonst immer mit Juve an. Ist ja langweilig. Die stehen auf Platz 10 mit 27 Punkten, trotz dieses Dreiers, die man geholt hat. Das sind 11 Punkte Rückstand auf den Europa League Platz. Und das sind als Vorsprung 12 Punkte auf den Abstieg. Okay, da wird man jetzt wohl nicht reinrutschen. Aber was ist denn da alles passiert in den letzten Monaten?
Puh, sehr viel eben. Müssen wir uns kurz halten. Ja, also es gibt sportliche Thematiken klarerweise, also Culli Balli, Mertens, teilweise Alan, es fehlen wirklich wichtige Spiele, verletzungsbedingt. Aber das ist nur ein kleiner Teil. Es gab ja im Herbst diese Spielerevolte gegen das Präsidium. Der Präsident hat da so ein Straftrainingslager einberufen. Da war Angelotti noch Trainer und die Mannschaft hat entschieden, da gehen wir nicht hin.
Was aber ja in Italien, glaube ich, gar nicht so untypisch ist, dass man so disziplinierende Trainingslager macht.
Genau, das ist nicht untypisch, aber dass die ganze Mannschaft nicht erscheint, das ist eher untypisch. Da ziehen sich jetzt noch auch rechtliche Prozesse vor Gericht, da geht es um die Zahlung von sehr hohen Strafen, die dann De Laurentis danach ausgesprochen hat gegen einzelne Spieler. Also der Präsident. Genau, da waren so Nummern im Rahmen von Strafen bis zu 300.000 Euro und solchen Geschichten. Und da ist einfach dieses Verhältnis zwischen Mannschaft, Verein, ja, ist einfach ein bisschen gekippt quasi und das hat Carlo Ancelotti nicht mehr kippen können quasi, der ja gehen musste. Und dann kam Gennaro Gattuso und der hat am Anfang halt all das geerbt sozusagen, hat da mal schön vier seiner ersten 5 Liga Spiele auch verloren, weil die Mannschaft halt verunsichert ist untereinander. Und ich glaube, Gattuso hat letzte Woche ein sehr vielsagendes Satz gesagt, wo man verstanden hat, wie tiefkundig er ist. Er hat gemeint, ich habe in meiner Karriere als Spieler auch mit sehr einigen Spielern zusammen gespielt, die ich alles andere als sympathisch fand, aber für den ich halt auf dem Feld trotzdem alles gegeben habe und hat damit den Prinzip ja zwischen den Zeilen zu verstehen gegeben, dass es mannschaftsinteren auch nicht passt. Also da kommt wirklich wahnsinnig viel zusammen und das Ligaspiel in der Woche davor gegen Fiorentina, das war brutal. Das war das schlechteste Spiel von Napoli, glaube ich, in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren. Also da hat nichts funktioniert. Da hast du dir echt gedacht, was ist aus der Mannschaft geworden, die am Anfang der Saison noch Liverpool geschlagen hat.
Die ja auch tatsächlich ungeschlagen ist international immer noch. Jetzt spielt man gegen Barca, Champions League Achtelfinale, wird nun mal eine andere Nummer.
Das ist erst ein paar Monate her, dass Napoli noch Napoli gespielt hat und das war alles weg und jetzt haben sie Gott sei Dank in den letzten fünf Tagen, denn unter der Woche gab es diesen Pokalsieg gegen Lazio. Da hat man schon gemerkt, da haben sie wieder ein bisschen Selbstvertrauen. Das waren so ein richtiger Pokalfight mit zwei roten Karten, vier Latten schüssen, verschossen in Elfmeter. Also so ein richtiger emotionaler Fight.
Aber natürlich wieder nur eins, nur diese langweilige Serie A.
Definitiv, ja, absolut. Da hast du völlig recht. Und jetzt eben im Spiel gegen den großen Rivalen aus dem Norden und jetzt halt nachgelegt. Deswegen freut mich sehr für Gattuse und auch die mussten zuletzt wirklich viel einstecken und vielleicht war das ja so ein kleiner Wendepunkt, dass sie jetzt wieder so ein bisschen in Spung kommen.
Aber das sind ja schon ganz schön krasse Verwerfungen. Ich meine, die Berufung von Gennaro Gattuso, das haben wahrscheinlich die meisten noch mitbekommen. Auch Diego Demme ist von Leipzig zu Neapel gewechselt, spätestens da haben wir mitbekommen, hey, Moment, da hat sie doch ein bisschen was getan, war da nicht mal jemand anderes Trainer. Wie schätzt du denn ihn jetzt als Trainer bei Napoli ein? Kam das für dich überraschend, wenn man das näher verfolgt hat? Also mein erster Gedanke war, passt denn das überhaupt?
Der Gedanke ist mehr als nachvollziehbar, ich glaube, den haben sich viele gestellt und viele haben auch gleich am Anfang schon die Antwort gegeben und gesagt, ne, das passt nicht, wenn man Gattuso jetzt nicht unbedingt mit so einer spielfreudigen, fußballerischen Mannschaft vielleicht in Verbindung bringen würde, wie Napoli es war. Aber ich glaube, Gattuso hat da auch ein bisschen, es ist einer, der hat sich auch in dieser schlechten Phase immer vor die Mannschaft gestellt und gesagt, es ist meine Schuld, meine Schuld. Ich glaube, er läuft auch ein bisschen unterm Radar. Jetzt brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht, weil wir jetzt zweimal jetzt gut gespielt haben. Erstmals ist es wieder zu hoch hängen, keine Frage. Aber es gab schon einen interessanten Fakt, in diesen Monaten, in denen er auf dem Trainermarkt war, hat er anscheinend 18 Anfragen abgelehnt. Der hat Anfragen aus ganz Europa gehabt, aus Italien sowieso, die Hälfte der Serie A auch aus Spanien anscheinend.
Und wovon rattet es bei mir im Kopf? Also meins wird angefragt, am Köln wird angefragt.
Ob jetzt deutsche Mannschaften auch im Spiel waren, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich finde, das ist schon ganz interessant mal zu hören, weil man hört, denkt immer, originale Gattuse, da kommt dieser Fighter und Motivator, der wird die halt heiß machen, aber mehr kann der wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich glaube, das ist zu kurz gedacht. Also der hat, glaube ich, schon auch als Trainer was auf dem Kasten, kam in diese unglaublich schwierige Situation rein. Und mal schauen, ob er sich jetzt da Schritt für Schritt zusammen mit der Mannschaft rausbuddelt. Das könnte der Anfang gewesen sein. Lass uns da nochmal ein paar Wochen darüber reden, ob es dann wirklich… Aber ich finde, ihm wird manchmal ein bisschen Unrecht getan, wenn man immer noch den Spieler-Gattuse vor Augen hat.
Ja klar, warum sollte er als Trainer genauso sein?
Und wie gesagt, die letzten zwei Spiele haben wirklich, da war dieser Wille, diese Leidenschaft da, aber halt eben auch die Qualität von Napoli, die ja immer noch mit den Spielern da ist. Die ist ja nicht weg. Und jetzt kommt sie hoffentlich so langsam wieder zum Vorschein.
Aber trotzdem ja dieser große Rückstand. Was würde denn in Neap passieren, wenn man das internationale Geschäft verpassen würde? Also ich glaube, ich...
Ja, vor dem Spieltag waren sie noch 13. Jetzt sind sie 10. Das schaut jetzt schon um einiges wieder besser aus. Boah, ich glaube, soweit... Carduso spricht auch immer davon, er will gar nichts wissen vom Mai und Juni. Er hat gesagt, wir müssen jetzt erstmal das Ding ins Laufen bringen.
Aber die Spieler ja. Ja, ja und vor allem, wenn ich höre, Präsident versus Spieler, da knacht es ganz gewaltig. Und ich gleichzeitig sehe, der wahrscheinliche Ausgang ist sportlich, dass man das internationale Geschäft verpasst. Mindestens die Champions League. Und dann gucke ich mir an, wer spielt da so bei Napoli? Welchen Anspruch haben diese Spiele? Dann könnte das ja einen ziemlich krassen Umbruch darauf beschuldigen.
Definitiv, das kann man nicht ausschließen. Einen Aspekt, den wir noch gar nicht hatten, Mertens und Kalle Hörn, zwei ganz wichtige Führungsspieler, da laufen die Verträge aus. Und da gab es lange anscheinend Signale, dass die nicht verlängert werden. Das hat sich ja auch nicht zur Besserung des Verhältnisses beigetragen. Also klar, im Sommer werden es da einige Fragezeichen geben. Fabian Ruiz zum Beispiel ist auf dem Zettel der Großen Spanier, Real Barca, Coulibaly ist immer am Thema. Aber, wie gesagt, sie haben jetzt im Winter nachgerüstet mit Demme, auch mit Lobotka, einen sehr interessanten Mann aus Spanien geholt. Sie haben jetzt schon ein Signal gezeigt, dass wir da schon weiter dran bleiben. Und jetzt glaube ich, momentan geht es wirklich für den Verein darum, sich jetzt erstmal wieder da wirklich peu à peu Spiel für Spiel ein bisschen rauszuarbeiten. Im Hintergrund werden klarerweise auch schon Richtung nächste Saison gedacht. Und ja, ich sage mal so, die Europa League Teilnahme wäre dann schon zumindest sehr förderlich, denn ich glaube, Richtung Champions League, da ist der Zug abgefahren. Also ich glaube, das sind zu viele Punkte.
Außer halt über den Champions League Titel. Aber da muss man ja noch Wasser aus dem Rennen nehmen. Hat denn Diego Demme gegen Juve gespielt?
Allerdings. Und er hat auch gegen Lazio von Anfang an gespielt und war wirklich zweimal richtig stabil im zentralen Mittelfeld. Also wirklich ganz, ganz starke zwei Spiele von ihm. Napoli, das war ein zentrales Thema. Die hatten so eine Defensive. Da gab es viele Probleme im Mittelfeld. Deswegen hat auch die Verteidigung gelitten. Teilweise auch Koulibaly und Manu Lasti, die eigentlich auf dem Papier starke Leute sind. Und da hat so ein Ohr in der Hand im Zentrum gefehlt. Und Demme ist da jetzt seit gefühlt zehn Tagen da in der Woche und hat die jetzt wirklich sofort übernommen. Wirklich, also gestern stark, am Dienstag vielleicht noch einen Tick stärker gegen Lazio. Top Einstand von ihm, absolut.
Faszinierend. Dann lass uns jetzt über Juve sprechen, die ja jetzt zwar dieses Spiel verloren haben, aber immer noch mit drei Punkten Vorsprung vor Inter bei nur zwei Niederlagen. Also es war die zweite Saisonniederlage. Das muss man dazu sagen, souverän auf Platz eins liegen. Wir haben, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, gefühlt war das im letzten Jahrhundert, nicht im letzten Jahrzehnt, dass wir das letzte Mal über Serie A gesprochen haben. Da haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass viele Dinge noch nicht zusammen passen bei Juve und dass da, dass sich da noch viel finden muss. Wie war denn jetzt so die Entwicklung?
Bis gestern eigentlich ganz gut. Also es hat wirklich so, man hat das Gefühl gehabt, dass so ab Ende Januar dann auch, dass so ein bisschen dieser Sare-Mechanismus peu à peu mehr greift. Es gab wirklich ein paar, also gerade Dybala und Ronaldo, die haben wirklich da vorne richtig Rabatz gemacht. Auch Higoin hat gut funktioniert. Also man hatte so das Gefühl, okay, diese ersten Monate mit Sare, diese Anpassung, so langsam ist sie vorbei und jetzt kommt so kleines Stückchen immer ein bisschen mehr. Da muss man sagen, da war das gestern definitiv ein Rückstück.
Aber es war ja auch nur ein Spiel.
Klar, es war ein Spiel, da muss man jetzt auch nicht so groß hängen. Aber es war halt ein wichtiges, ein großes Spiel. Und da hat Napoleon wirklich den Schneider abgekauft. Und was auch interessant war, er hat gestern, Sare hat man auch nicht damit gerechnet, er hat mit Ronaldo, Higoin und Tibala angefangen, in diesem großen Dreierangriff, wo er noch vor ein paar Wochen, Monaten gesagt hat, ach, das machen wir nur in einzelnen Phasen. Vielleicht mal ein Spiel in einer Phase. Und gestern hat er, glaube ich, auch so als Statement, wollte er zeigen, okay, schau, ich komme nach Neapel, jetzt fangen wir mit den Dreien einfach an. Und gestern haben sie nicht funktioniert. Nochmal, brauchen wir nicht zu groß aufhängen. Sie haben auch schon ein paar Mal sehr gut harmoniert. Aber gestern, wie gesagt, hat einiges von diesen positiven Entwicklungen, die es davor gab, hat man gestern sehr wenig davon gesehen.
Cristiano Ronaldo steht aktuell bei 17 Treffern, damit weit hinter dem Tore-Monster aus der Serie A. Thierry Möbele mit 23 Treffern nach 21 Spieltagen. Da werden gerade Rekorde ins Visier genommen. Aber wie hat sich denn jetzt Ronaldo da eingeführt? Wir hatten ja auch durchaus mal die Phase in der Saison, wo er das Stadion verlassen hat nach Auswechslung, wo es deutlich gekriset hat für alle sichtbar.
Also bei Ronaldo ist die Entwicklung eindeutig nach oben. Also körperlich ist er momentan wirklich brutal fit. Das ist echt beeindruckend, auch unter der Woche im Pokal gegen Rom, da hat er einen Antritt vor dem 1-0 gedacht, wo du denkst, wow, okay, alles klar, Cristiano Ronaldo hat his best. Also er ist momentan physisch brutal stark, was sehr interessant ist. Er arbeitet mittlerweile mit Francis Obiquelo, dem Sprint-Europameister, in Portugiesen zusammen. Der war Anfang Januar einfach, fliegt er mal darüber nach Portugal und arbeitet mit dem an der Sprintarbeit. Also auch nur, um diese Perfektion dieses Mannes zu verdeutlichen. Also wie die Körperhaltung ist, wie diagonal der Körper im Moment des Sprints ist. Also es ist wirklich ein Perfektionist vor dem Herrn. Und momentan ist er, was das körperliche, spritzige, dynamische anbelangt, wirklich wieder da, wo sie ihn bei Juve gehofft haben, hinzubekriegen. Und ich glaube, das ist ja auch der entscheidende Faser der Saison. Jetzt kommen die Champions-League-K.o.-Spiele, Ronaldo ist da, darüber muss man sich momentan keine Sorgen machen.
Und was sagt das jetzt über die ganze Serie A aus, oder eigentlich um die Spitzengruppe der Serie A aus, dass Juve eigentlich eine sehr dominante Saison spielt, mit nur zwei Niederlagen und drei Unentschieden sind jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Und dennoch sind es nur drei Punkte auf Inter und fünf Punkte auf Lazio.
Ja, und vergiss Lazio nicht, denn Lazio hat noch ein Nachholspiel. Die könnten rein theoretisch jetzt sogar am Anfang Februar auf zwei herankommen. Also wirklich, ja das sagt erstmal, dass das mega spannend ist. Und das Paradoxe daran ist, du hast ja völlig recht, ist, dass Inter zuletzt sogar einige Punkte liegen hat lassen.
Wie Unentschieden aus den letzten sechs Spielen.
Ja, und wie, was für Unentschieden. Die waren jetzt zu Hause im Wochenende gegen Kalia, 1-0 vorne, spielen 1-1. Die haben in Florenz lang 1-0 geführt, kriegen am Schluss das 1-1. Also Inter könnte sogar vorne sein, muss man definitiv so sagen. Und das sagt logischerweise aus, dass es ja ein sehr spannender Kampf ist, dass Inter das sehr gut macht, obwohl sie momentan sogar, ich glaube, nach gestern, da wird sich Herr Konte so ein bisschen den Allerwertesten beißen. Wenn die hätten gestern diese drei Punkte mitnehmen müssen, dann wären sie auf einen dran.
Jetzt einmal verloren, Inter, dass sie so können.
Genau, und heute ist Herr Ericsson aus London eingeflogen, hat die medizinischen Tests gemacht. Yang von Man United und Moses von Chelsea hat Konte jetzt ja auch als Geschenk im Januar bekommen. Vielleicht kommen noch Chirou, heißt es in den letzten Tagen. Also Inter hat eindeutig was vor in dieser Saison.
Wahnsinn, und der Konte-Effekt, der ja quasi durch den Halbstund prognostiziert wurde. Jeder wollte Konte haben. Ich glaube, wir haben über Milan und Konte ja auch mal gesprochen. Und jetzt ist er bei Inter gelandet. Aber ja, er scheint das mal wieder an der weiteren Station zu erfüllen, was man an Hoffnungen in ihn hineinsteckt.
Ja, definitiv. Keine Frage. Momentan, wie gesagt, ist sogar der Eindruck, dass zuletzt noch ein bisschen mehr möglich gewesen wäre. Gestern gab es wieder so einen, muss man leider auch sagen, so ein bisschen typischen Konte. Hat er sich bei der Pressekonferenz nicht präsentiert, weil er so sauer war. Das ist auch so manchmal, ein bisschen dieses Beleidigsein. Es gab gestern auch, darf man nicht vergessen, Lautaro Martinez hat in der Nachspielzeit die rote Karte wegen Schiedsrichterbeschimpfung gesehen. Da ist es gut möglich, dass der jetzt mehrere Spiele gesperrt wird. Die rechne schon damit, dass er auch im Derby gegen Milan in zwei Spieltagen fehlt. Also das war gestern schon sehr angespannt, sehr emotional. Ja, also bei Inter, das kriegst du mit Konte. Wenn du Konte hast, dann ist immer der Deckel ganz knapp vorm Hochgehen. Also das ist ja auch die große Stärke von Konte. Er schafft es, seine Spiele einfach so on fire zu halten, so, wie soll man sagen, aufzuheizen. Das kann halt manchmal logischerweise auch ein bisschen dann drübergehen. Oder halt, aber wie gesagt, es sind drei Punkte. Anfang März ist Inter gegen Juve. Das große Duell, da ist jetzt auch schon, merkt man so ein bisschen die Vorspannung da. Also ich hoffe, dass das Inter schafft, da dran zu bleiben, um das Ganze ganz, ganz heiß werden zu lassen, auch Richtung Saisonende.
Ja, vor allem, was ich so faszinierend finde, ist, es gibt ja mehrere solche Trainer, die über die Motivation kommen. Bei Conte steckt aber halt noch eine viel taktischere Komponente dahinter als bei vielen anderen. Und das, finde ich, äußert sich auch in einer Zahl, und das ist die 18. Also obwohl Inter so viel über Motivation und Emotion kommt, hat man erst 18 Gegentreffer kassiert, stellt die aktuell beste Abwehr der Liga. Und gerade in den letzten Spielen waren ja ein paar Gegentreffer mit dabei, wo man sich gedacht hat, okay gut, woher kam das jetzt? Und das, finde ich, ist eben das Interessante, weil das haben eben nur ganz wenige Trainer, dass beides stimmt.
Diese Kombi, ja, definitiv. Und man darf nicht vergessen, Lautaro, Martínez und Lukaku, wie die vorne schon wunderbar harmoniert haben. Also das ist wirklich eine Mannschaft mit brutal viel Qualität. Wie gesagt, momentan der einzige Vorwurf, den sie sich momentan wirklich gefallen lassen muss, ist sie. Und das ist zum Beispiel der Unterschied. Juve hatte gerade auch im Herbst einige solcher Spiele, wo Juve definitiv besser als paar Maudinese wie andere waren. Aber Juve gewinnt dieses Spiel dann 2-1, 1-0. Und Inter hat jetzt schon mehrfach zu Punkte liegen lassen. Und ich hoffe, dass ich das nicht recht, weil das Interessante daran war, sie waren immer vorne. Und dann ist halt die Frage, entweder du legst nach oder du musstest halt mal das 1-0 über die Zeit bringen. Und das ist ihnen zuletzt nicht gelungen, sonst wäre Inter momentan sogar schon einer Tabellenspitze.
Das ist wirklich eine andere Situation als in den letzten Jahren in der Serie A. Das muss man mal so sagen. Was eben auch an Lazio liegt, über die hast du schon gesprochen, die haben ein Spiel weniger. Aktuell 5 Punkte Rückstand auf Juve und das könnten eben, der Theorie nach, auch nur 2 Punkte Rückstand sein. Was läuft denn bei Lazio außer Giro Immobile? 23 Treffer. Das ist jetzt nicht so schlecht in 20 Spielen, würde ich mal sagen. Aber es kann ja nicht nur an einem Spieler hängen.
Ne, also über Lazio müssen wir jetzt definitiv mal sprechen, über was Simone Nsagi da…
Du bist auch auf der Stuhlkante schon nach vorne gerichtet.
Ne, das ist halt… Ich meine, gerade das Thema Lazio ist ja eines, das oft wegen Nicht-Fußball-Themen zu Recht sehr kritisch gesehen wird. Keine Frage. Aber ich finde, man muss jetzt halt auch mal festhalten, was die da sportlich leisten. Das ist wirklich momentan ganz großes Kino. Also, die hatten am Wochenende jetzt das Derby, haben eins eins gespielt und haben die elf vorangegangenen Spiele gewonnen. Die sind mit elf Siegen in Serie, Serie A-Siegen da reingegangen. Und klar, wie du sagst, die Schlagzeilen gehören Giro Immobile. Keine Frage, wenn einer so eine Quote hat, auch völlig zu Recht. Aber das Schöne daran ist, dass diese Mannschaft viel, viel mehr als Giro Immobile ist. Also da ist wirklich die Handschrift von Simone Nsagi… Ich muss wirklich sagen, dass sie auch so einer, der oft unter dem Radar läuft, Simone Nsagi, ein ganz guter Trainer, der hat wirklich die letzten Jahre jedes Jahr Schritt für Schritt gemacht. Jetzt haben sie wieder im Dezember Juve im Supercup geschlagen. Lazio ist sie, wenn man sich mal anschaut, die letzten Jahre. Juve hat wirklich nicht viele Titel in Italien liegen lassen. Also es sind so Krümel, die so abfallen für den Rest. Und im Prinzip hat sich den Rest in den letzten Jahren immer Lazio geschnappt. Lazio war auch die Mannschaft, die Juve in dieser Saison zweimal geschlagen hat. In der Liga und eben im Superpokal. Lazio hat den Pokal in den Jahren zweimal gewonnen, hat den Superpokal zweimal gewonnen. Also da ist auch so ein bisschen so eine Winnermentalität entstanden. Und Immobile ist klar der Mann, dem Schlagzeilen gehören. Das Spiel ist wunderbar für ihn ausgelegt. Aber du hast allein das Mittelfeldzentrum mit Lucas Leyva, Milinkovic Savic und Luis Alberto. Ich würde sagen, da findest du in Italien nicht viele bessere Mittelfeldzentralen. Also da steckt schon sehr viel Plan dahinter. Die personellen Strukturen sind sehr langfristig ausgelegt. Simone Nsage ist seit vier Jahren da, war 2010 noch Spieler, ist dann direkt bei Lazio, hat aufgehört, ist in die Jugend reingegangen direkt als Trainer. Lothito Iglitare, den man in Deutschland auch kennt. Da ist sehr viel personelle Konstanz und die zahlt sich jetzt wirklich peu à peu aus. Und Lazio spielt wirklich einen richtig, richtig feinen Ball. Also ich würde mir echt wünschen, dass die jetzt Anfang Februar das Nachholspiel gewinnen, weil dann, wie gesagt, sind die auf zwei Punkte dran. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass die dann am Ende auch noch um den Scudetto mitspielen, aber momentan ist das wirklich richtig, richtig schön anzuschauen.
Wie die Bundesliga atmet die Serie A auf. Es gibt wieder ein Titelrennen. Das Nachholspiel ist gegen Hellas Verona, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Genau.
Wir liegen aktuell auf Platz 9 für alle diejenigen da draußen, die sich das jetzt gefragt haben. Und was spielt Lazio dann für einen Fußball? Ich sehe, wenn ich mir die Zahlen angucke, sehe ich auch eine sehr gute Abwehr. 19 Gegentreffer erst aus den 20 Spielen, damit aktuell die zweitbeste Abwehr. Serie A und mit 47 Toren sogar sieben Tore mehr als ein Juve unter Sarri.
Ja, also ich, wenn ich Lazio so mit ein, zwei kurzen Sätzen beschreiben würde, würde ich sagen, es gibt in Italien kein Team, das so zielspräbig in die Tiefe, in die Räume reinspielt. Also deswegen, klar, wenn du Ciro Immobile hast, sobald der Raum vor sich hat, sobald der mit Tempo auf die Kette zulaufen kann, auf den 16er, dann brennt das einfach. Und dieses Spiel eben von Lazio, gerade mit diesen drei in Zentrum, das machen die wirklich gut. Lukas Leyva ist so ein bisschen der Dirigent, Regisseur, der so ein bisschen unterm Radar auch läuft. Der verteilt es gut. Und dann hast du aber mit Luis Alberto, der mit Abstand der beste Vorlagengeber, der sehr heiß ist. Der setzt eben diese Pässe in die Tiefe. Milinkovic Savic geht diese Wege auch richtig gut rein. Hat man ja auch schon das Thema vor zwei, drei Jahren, war der mega gehypt, dann wurde es ein bisschen ruhiger und ich glaube, das hat ihm sogar gut getan. Weil jetzt ist er vielleicht nicht mehr so im Zentrum, aber was der an Physis mitbringt, auch an sich vorne mit einschalten, diese Wege in die Tiefe reingehen. Über außen ist richtig Rabatz, da kommt über rechts Lazzari, einer von Spal, so ein ganz fleißiger Mann, der die Linie rauf und runter marschiert in diesen 3-5-2, über links auch. Also das ist wirklich eine Mannschaft. Wie gesagt, sobald Raum da ist und die suchen sich die Räume, da geht viel über Doppelpässe, das geht in höchstem Tempo nach vorne und dann klarerweise hast du so ein Immobile, der momentan, wo du das Gefühl hast, was der anfasst, klappt einfach. Also es ist wirklich auch schön anzuschauen, was Lazio zu bieten hat.
Und hatte Immobile nicht letzte Saison auch schon so eine gute Spielzeit?
Definitiv.
Also es ist ja jetzt nicht so, weil es hört sich jetzt so ein bisschen nach einem Einmalphänomen an, aber im Grunde knipst er ja jetzt 3 Jahre an.
Genau, jetzt ist es gerade brutal, sagen wir es so, aber der hat letztes Jahr auch schon eine Bomben-Saison gehabt. Also Rom und Giro Immobile, das funktioniert einfach. Simonen Sage war ja auch ein Weltklasse oder – sorry – Weltklasse war sein Bruder, er war vielleicht eine kleine Stufe drunter, aber war auch ein guter Serie-A-Stürmer. Die zwei finden sich, die hatten ganz interessant. Anfang der Saison gab es mal eine Szene, da hat er ihn ausgewechselt, 20 Minuten vor Schluss, und Immobile war stinksauer, weil er halt noch eine Bude machen wollte. Er hat ihn wirklich beim Gang Richtung Bank beschimpft und so, und da hast du auch gemerkt – das sagen ganz viele – die Riesenstärke von ihm, der ist ein wahnsinnig guter Moderator. Der hat ihn gleich auf der Bank auch noch mal kurz rund gemacht, hat aber gleich danach gesagt, nach dem Spiel hat dem Immobile auch noch mal auf dem Nachhauseweg angerufen, hat sich sofort entschuldigt. Und die zwei sind als Stürmer, die wissen, wie sie damit umzugehen haben, hat den gleich wieder gesagt, alles gut, aber so was nicht mehr. Und wie gesagt, sogar Sven-Göran Eriksson, der Meistertrainer von Lazio 2000, hat gesagt, es ist wirklich beeindruckend, wie Sage es schafft, eben dieses Kollektiv zu moderieren. Also es ist wirklich eine ganz große Stärke, sozusagen die Menschenführung auch von Simone Insari.
Ich meine, wir haben diesen Stürmer ja nur mal kurz gesehen bei Dortmund 2014, 2015. Dortmund hatte damals drei Tore gemacht und jetzt gucken wir uns die Zahlen der letzten Jahre an. Also jetzt 23, letzte Saison 15, vorletzte Saison 29 Treffer und da vor 23 Treffer. Also das ist jetzt einfach die vierte Saison in Folge.
Und das Interessante, weil du die Zahlen gerade hast, du siehst auch immer, es sind relativ viele Vorlagen auch dabei. Also er ist kein Ego-Zocker. Es ist auch einer, jetzt hat er wieder die Saison schon fünf Vorlagen. Das ist einer, der auch gut spielerisch da reinpasst, der dann den zweiten Stürmer meistens Korea auch mitnimmt, der oft gerne auch ablegt auf Milinkovic Savic zum Beispiel, der dann vorne mit reingeht. Also das ist schon ein kompletter Stürmer. Da reden wir jetzt nicht nur von einem, der halt vorne da sein Füßen reinhält, sondern er passt einfach eins zu eins wunderbar in dieses Lazio-Simoninsagesystem.
Meine Güte, sie haben es einfach mit Stürmern, die Iro im Vornamen haben. Okay, gut, keine Ahnung, wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin. Legen wir den Mantel des Schweigens drüber und reden über die Roma. Da reißt jetzt schon punktetechnisch ein bisschen ab. Sieben Punkte Rückstand auf Lazio und er nach hinten auf Atalanta. Da muss Roma gucken, sich in den Champions League-Plätzen zu halten. Wie gestaltet sich denn da die Lage?
Ja, ich glaube, wenn man sich das momentan anschaut, also ich glaube nicht, dass sich Juve, Inter und Lazio das da vorne noch nehmen lassen, weil Lazio auch so brutal konstant ist. Also ich glaube, es geht dieses Jahr dann wirklich um den vierten Platz Richtung Champions League. Ja, und das ist ein heißes Duell zwischen Roma und Atalanta. Also die Roma hat sich definitiv auch stabilisiert. Gestern eigentlich das Derby, hätten sie von den Spielanteilen her, von den Chancen auch gewinnen müssen, sollten. Ja, das macht, von Seca macht es gut. Also hatten auch immer wieder mal so einen kleinen Hänger, aber Cecho spielt wieder eine richtig dominante Saison vorne drin. Pellegrini, Lorenzo Pellegrini hat wirklich den nächsten Schritt gemacht zu einem wirklich ganz, ganz wichtigen Mittelfeldspieler, der auch wahnsinnig viel mitbringt. Ich hoffe, dass wir ihn dann auch im Sommer bei der EM das ein oder andere Mal sehen. Das ist ein sehr kompletter Mittelfeldspieler, ein sehr technisch feiner, viel Übersicht. Auch diese Wege vorne mit reingeht, wirklich so ein moderner, technisch starker Mittelfeldspieler. Gefällt mir sehr gut. Ja, da ist Qualität da. Chris Smalling hinten macht das richtig, richtig gut. Da gab es, glaube ich, auch ein paar Skeptiker, was macht dieser Smalling jetzt in Rom? Aber der ist da ganz wichtig im Zentrum, leitet diese Abwehr. Mancini, der junge Mann, der von Atalanta gekommen ist, hat sich da total neben ihm festgespielt. Die zwei sind da ja total gut aufeinander abgestimmt. Also die Roma ist auch eine Mannschaft. Wenn mal einer sagt, er will sich mal ein Spiel raussuchen, da kann man ohne Bedenken auch die Roma nehmen, denn das lässt sich auch gut anschauen.
Okay, weil die Zahlen sehen gar nicht so spektakulär aus. Das finde ich so als Interessante. Wenn du mir einfach nur gesagt hättest, okay, beide Römer Vereine, der eine hatte die Torbilanz 47 zu 19, und der andere von 38 zu 23, hätte ich genau umgedreht getippt, hätte nicht gedacht, dass die Roma diejenige ist, die weniger Treffer geschossen hat und mehr kassiert hat.
Nee, auf dem Papier wahrscheinlich nicht, oder vor der Saison auch nicht. Wie gesagt, die Roma ist halt immer so ein bisschen, die Roma ist so eine Mannschaft, die sehr viel so über, wie sagt man es so, über Emotionen kommt. Also die Roma in dem einen…
Der konnte unter dem Mannschaft.
Ja, vielleicht schon. Also die Roma, wenn die Roma einen Sahnetag hat und dann auch das Ambiente stimmt, vielleicht das Olympica gut voll ist.
Basta damals ist das Spiel.
Genau, dann kannst du mit der Roma… Die Roma kann in einem Spiel alles sozusagen raushauen. Das Problem ist halt, dass die Roma dann halt auch 2x 1-1 in Verona und 1-0 in Udine verliert, jetzt blöd gesagt oder so. Also das so ausgedrückt. Und klar haben sie diese Saison auch wieder Punkte liegen lassen. Ich glaube, sie haben vor kurzem mal eine Heimniederlage, wo du dir auch denkst, das darf dir eigentlich nicht passieren, im Champions-League-Rennen. Aber sie sind relativ konstant und ich bin mir sicher, dass, wie gesagt, dass sie da ganz, ganz wichtiges Wörtchen nehmen, um diesen Platz 4 mitreden werden.
Sie haben 2x gegen Torino Vereine verloren und gegen Juve kannst du noch verlieren, aber gegen den FC Torino.
Stimmt, das war die Heimniederlage in Torino, genau.
Das sollte dann nicht so passieren. Und dann haben wir eine Mannschaft wie ein Feuerwerk.
Ja, da muss man wieder kurz, ja gut, Atalanta, das hatten wir schon ein paar Mal, aber es bleibt da bereits.
Ja, aber dass das einfach so konstant bleibt. Ich meine, da ist ja auch Fluktuation bei den Spielern mit drin. Gleichzeitig ist es ja ein sehr intensiver Spiel. Ich finde das schon erstaunlich, dass das jetzt einfach sofort wird. Im Grunde jetzt schon in der dritten Saison ja so erfolgt.
Genau, und das finde ich nämlich auch das Beeindruckende, das besonders Beeindruckende ist das Selbstverständnis, das Atalanta mittlerweile einfach hat. 57er-ziehende Tore. Ich sag's dir, das ist ein Spektakelgarant. Jetzt sitzen wir zufällig heute da nach dem 7-0 vor zwei Tagen. Ich weiß nicht, hast du das Tor von Josip Ilicic gesehen?
Nein.
Dann schau dir das mal danach an. Das hat im Netz etwas die Runde gemacht. Also er hat drei Buden gemacht, aber es gibt eins, da liegt der Ball einfach an der Mittellinie beim Freistoß und er sieht, dass der Torhüter draußen ist und zack sich. Alles klar, ich weiß, was ich zu tun habe. Ja, aber es ist, also Atalanta, ich bleibe dabei. Für mich eine der spektakulärsten Mannschaften ganz Europas. Also nicht nur Italiens. Das ist wirklich faszinierend. Ich habe auch vor Kurzem war Inter-Atalanta, das war ein Feuerwerk an Intensität, an Dynamik und auch ein Spiel, das Atalanta am Ende, Moriel verschießt einen Elfmeter, trotz Rückstand eigentlich noch gewinnen kann oder muss in Mailand, in San Siro gegen Inter. Also Atalanta ist wirklich, jetzt hatten sie diese 7-0 Anfang des Jahres, gab es ein 5-0 gegen Parma, ein 5-0 gegen Milan auch zum Ende des letzten Jahres. Also wenn die ins Rollen kommen, dann Gnade dir. Das ist wirklich, und für mich so als Überbegriff bleibt da einfach, Pep Guardiola hat dieses Jahr in der Gruppenphase gemeint, wo die ja aufeinander getroffen sind, ein Spiel gegen Atalanta ist wie ein Besuch beim Zahnarzt. Das kann sehr unangenehm werden. Und ich finde, das bringt es wirklich auf den Punkt.
Wurde das Zahnarzt, das hat doch, glaube ich, Clemens Fritz über Auswärtsspiele München gesagt, hat er das nicht damals gesagt, als Guardiola Trainer bei Bayern war?
Oh, das ist eine gute Frage, das weiß ich jetzt.
Wie witzig, das wäre, wenn Pep Guardiola diese Worte von Clemens Fritz in seinem Herzen bewegt hat und dann auspackt, wenn er gegen Atalanta in der Champions League 1-1 spielt.
Definitiv, ja. Aber wie gesagt, ich finde, das bringt es wirklich auf den Punkt, weil Atalanta, du hast die Rauschen heran, das ist dynamisch, da ist ein System dahinter von Gasperini, aber das ist mit sehr viel Leben gefüllt. Robin Goossens, glaube ich, sollten wir auch nochmal kurz ansprechen. Ich glaube, es sind sieben Tore, wenn ich mich nicht mehr...
Sieben Tore, vier Vorlagen.
Ja, richtig. Wir reden von einem Außenverteidigungen, klar, von einem Außenverteidigungen, 3-5-2, also einer, der schon vorne mit reingeht. Kostic? Ja, vielleicht, ja, in die Richtung, genau, hat am Wochenende auch wieder getroffen. Also, das ist, es ist ein Feuerwerk einfach. Man muss ihn anschauen. Ilicic, Ilicic ist wirklich so einer. Ich glaube, den haben nicht so viele auf dem Zettel, ist ja auch klar. Aber wenn der einen Tag, einen Sahnetag hat, dann kann der alles kaputt spielen. Der hat bei diesen 2-5-0, hat auch jeweils zwei Buden gemacht. Ich kann nur jeden mal ans Herz raten, gib mal irgendwie bei Twitter oder bei YouTube Ilicic Tore ein. Du glaubst es manchmal nicht, was der für Sachen auspackt. Also das ist so ein Gefühlsspiel auch. Du hast Alejandro Gomez, der so ein bisschen stellvertretend für die wirkt, der das vorne alles koordiniert. Zapata war die halbe Zeit verletzt, deswegen machen die trotzdem 59 Buden. Eben Gosens Hammer. Muriel als Aushilfsstürmer hat 12 Buden auf dem Zettel. Also das ist...
Wer ist da der Kaderplaner? Über den Trainer haben wir ja schon mal gesprochen, Gasperine. Dass der jetzt nicht so falsch sein kann, das haben wir jetzt alle verstanden. Wer hat den Kader so zusammengestellt? Weil da sind ja Leute mit dabei, das glaubt man ja nicht.
Das schöne ist zum Beispiel, Gomez und Ilicic haben das Kamm jetzt im Zuge dieses Wochenendspieltags, haben Atalanta zusammen für 10 Millionen Euro verpflichtet. Also das ist die Familie Percassi, das ist der Präsident eben. Der kommt auch aus der Gegend, ist mit Bergamo ganz eng verwurzelt und sein Sohn ist der Sportdirektor.
Normalerweise ist es doch so.
Da sitzen einige Leute die Ahnung.
Das ist eine Martin-Kin-Struktur, aber es funktioniert.
Bei Atalanta muss ich wirklich sagen, das hat sich ja auch wirklich schon in den letzten Jahren angedeutet. Da haben wir auch schon mal angerissen, Atalanta hat immer noch mit die beste Jugendarbeit in ganz Italien. Also da war ja schon ein Fundament da, aber die haben das jetzt wirklich auf ein neues Niveau gehoben, das neue Stadion wurde gebaut, also da funktioniert der ganze Verein. Da geht vieles in die richtige Richtung. Wie du sagst, sie haben jedes Jahr wieder mal eins oder zwei ihrer Jungs für 30 Millionen verkauft oder so. Und trotzdem geht das aber weiter, weil die Nachschub haben, weil die dafür sorgen, weil die sehr mit Weitblick Leute verpflichten. Kulusevski an Juve, ja, der kommt von Atalanta, da kommen wieder mal 40 Millionen rein oder so und die wissen dann einfach auch gute Dinge damit, mit dem Geld anzufangen. Also es ist wirklich ein, ich würde mittlerweile sagen, es ist ein Modellverein für sehr viele europäische Vereine, was Atalanta da macht.
Das ist echt absolut faszinierend. Und Robin Gosens, also wir haben jetzt die Zahlen zitiert, spielt er denn, und er spielt ja auch spielerisch eine entscheidende Rolle.
Das ist eben, wie gesagt, diese Außen auch hier, die marschieren vorne mit rein. Für mich ist immer so der typische Atalanta-Spielzug, da kannst du die Uhr danach stellen. Wenn es über rechts geht, dann kannst du dir sicher sein, dass Gosens am Langen Pfosten auf jeden Fall den Weg mit reinmacht ins Sturmzentrum. Deswegen hat er auch schon sieben Tore. Wenn es über ihn geht, dann geht es von rechts. Hatteburg oder Kastanje mit vorne rein. Man muss sich wirklich mal so ein Standbild anschauen, wie viel Atalanta-Spieler bei einem Angriff im gegnerischen Strafraum anzufinden. Das ist brutal. Das hast du dann aber auch die Dynamik und Laufstärke. Die laufen die Löcher dann auch im Idealfall nach hinten wieder zu. Also es ist nicht nur so hurra, okay, wir laufen jetzt alle blind nach vorne. Es ist toll anzuschauen. Ich kann jedem nur raten, du kannst dir blind ein Atalanta-Spiel raussuchen. Du wirst ja nichts falsch machen. Die Dynamik, die Taktik, der Taktikplan ist das eine. Aber da ist auch brutale Offensivqualität dahinter. Wenn Illicic schon kommt, kann da jeden Moment was passieren.
Toll. Ach, Wahnsinn, was für eine Geschichte. Über die letzten fünf Spielzeiten gesehen hat Atalanta 306 Millionen Euro laut Transfermarkt.de eingenommen und nur 205 Millionen investiert. Damit hat man das zweitbeste Saldo nach dem FC Genua. Also jetzt, wenn wir mal einfach die Zahlen von Transfermarkt.de als Basis nehmen. Aber das zeigt so ein bisschen das, was du gesagt hast, dass man das Geld gut einsetzt und damit auch noch einen guten Schnitt macht.
Und nicht nur eben in Spieler, sondern immer auch in die Infrastruktur, neues Trainingszentrum, neues Stadion. Also das ist auch ein Verein, der modern denkt, wo es nicht nur darum geht, okay, welchen neuen Spieler holen wir uns noch im Winter dazu, um das vielleicht aufzupeppen, sondern das ist schon ein sehr ganzheitliches System.
Ach, dass es sowas auch noch gibt im modernen Fußball. Wer hätte das gedacht? Lass uns mal so ein bisschen über die nächsten drei Vereine zusammen sprechen. Kaliyari, Pamarcaixo und Milan. Alle mit 31 Punkten bebalgen sich gerade um den Europa League-Platz. Und vor allem Kaliyari kommt jetzt aus einer echt schlechten Phase heraus.
Und ist immer da noch mit drin.
Genau, das ist immer noch drin.
Das zeigt, dass sie davor einen sehr guten Bonus hatten. Kaliyari ist, wie du sagst, zuletzt ein bisschen punktemäßig ins Stocken geraten. Aber zwar ganz lang logisch die Sensationsmannschaft. Also der Symbolmann ist logisch Raja Nainggolan, der verlorene Sohn, der zurückkam von Inter, den Konter nicht mehr wollte aufgrund seiner, ja, sag ich mal…
Ach, der war vor Inter bei Kaliyari, oder?
Genau, der war da schon. Also bei der Roma davor, aber er ist von Kaliyari nach Rom gekommen. Ist wirklich sehr verwurzelt mit der Insel. Hat da seine ersten großen Schritte gemacht. Und ja, dann ging es halt mehr um Sachen, die außerhalb des Fußballplatzes passiert sind. Scheint wohl nicht der äußerst fleißigste Fußballer zu sein, aber halt ein sehr genialer Fußball. Und das hat er gestern wiederum kurz gezeigt. Er ist einfach als der, der von Inter weggescheucht wurde, zurück zu St.Sierad gestern 1-1 gemacht. Hat sich danach hingestellt, hat gemeint, irgendwie tut es ihm leid, weil er liebt die Inter-Fans und er liebt das Interumfeld. Aber er hat gesagt, irgendwie tut es ihm auch nicht leid, denn er wurde von ein paar Verantwortlichen so ein bisschen als Spielerchen behandelt, hat er gemeint.
Die Schäffchen-Affäre aus Italienisch.
Da kommt halt, da merkt man, da geht es halt logisch auch um Emotionen. Und ja, in Angolan reißt diese ganze Kaleri-Mannschaft mit. Ist logischerweise nicht der einzige Faktor, aber hebt die halt schon nochmal auf ein anderes Niveau. Und ja, toll, dass sie da immer noch im Spiel sind, sozusagen. Um die internationalen Plätze.
Und dahinter hätte ich jetzt auch nicht direkt Parma erwartet.
Ne, definitiv nicht. Parma ist so eine Mannschaft, die auch definitiv, glaube ich, ich glaube, wenn du vier Leute fragst, auch in Italien, wo ist denn Parma eigentlich noch dabei? Ich glaube, da würden dann eher so kommen 12, 13, 14. Die laufen auch unterm Radar. Das ist eine Mannschaft, die, sie hat logisch mit Kulusevski, den haben, ich weiß nicht, ob wir beim letzten Mal angesprochen hatten, da war es noch so dieser Geheimtipp, dieser junge schwedische Baujahr 2000, den sich jetzt Juve eben geangelt hat im Winter. Und da reden wir über ein Investment von knapp 44 Millionen. Also ich glaube 39 plus 5. Da ist was da, es sind die Zahlen, klar, 5 plus 7, aber es ist viel mehr.
Also 5 Tore, 7 Assists.
Genau, danke. Und das ist, der ist 19, der hat eine Spielintelligenz, ein Gefühl für einen Raum schon, geht da vorne mit rein. Also es ist kein Zufall, dass Juve da definitiv in die Tasche gegriffen hat. Es hieß auch immer, dass Inter eigentlich schon so gut wie dran war. Konnte, wollte ihn unbedingt. Und dann hat anscheinend jetzt im Januar Juve einfach nochmal 5 Mille draufgelegt. Er hat gesagt, nix da, der kommt zu uns. Und ja, soviel, um es dem abzuschließen. Der Junge ist von Atalanta ein paar Mal ausgeliehen. Also das Geld fließt nach Bergamo.
Ja, Wahnsinn, verrückt. Okay, das hatte ich gar nicht mitbekommen mit Kolosseski. Gut, dass wir darüber geredet haben. Und dann die Milan, über die Milan sprechen wir ja jedes Mal, wenn wir über die Serie A sprechen, ja auch aus guten Gründen. Also immerhin jetzt mal wieder gewonnen, die letzten Spiele und den Anschluss an die Europa League hergestellt. Das Krisenbarometer, wo steht's?
Ja, seit Zlatan E-Punkt zurückgekommen ist, muss man jetzt wirklich so sagen. Ja, Milan hat die letzten drei Liga-Spiele jetzt gewonnen. Und das waren die drei Liga-Spiele, in denen Zlatan von Anfang an gespielt hat. Sie haben, glaube ich, 0-0 gegen Sampdoria gespielt, da kam er rein. Das war sein Debüt. Und jetzt die letzten drei Spiele mit ihm in der Startelf haben sie gewonnen. Ich glaube, das spielt halt auch mit rein. Das haben viele thematisiert. Auch Conte hat es zum Beispiel gesagt, wenn du wie an Ibrahimovic zurückholst. Klar, das ist nicht mehr der Ibrahimovic von vor 5, 6, 7, 8 Jahren. Aber was Ibrahimovic auf jeden Fall mitbringt, ist diese Persönlichkeit und dieses Mitreiserische. Und gerade bei Milan hängt sein Herzen dran, das hat er immer gesagt, hat man schon gemerkt, dass da irgendwie ein Ruck durch die Mannschaft gegangen ist. Und vor allen Dingen, das glaube ich, darf man echt nicht unterschätzen, ich glaube, das sind so ein paar Spieler bei Milan, weißt du, das ist, das hat man glaube ich auch schon mal das Thema. Milan, der Norma ist immer noch riesig, groß, die Geschichte, auch der Druck, aber was da teilweise logisch in den letzten Jahren auch, ich sage mal, Spieler einfach da waren, die glaube ich nie den Anspruch gehabt hätten, bei Milan überhaupt spielen zu können. Und die haben da ein schönes Leben, das darfst du nicht vergessen, es ist Mailand, die verdienen gutes Geld und dann laufen die wahrscheinlich glaube ich manchmal so rum, schau, ich bin Milan-Spieler, läuft. Und wenn dann so ein Zlatan da reinkommt und denen klipp und klar sagt, weil ich glaube, das ist klar, das hat er auch ein paar Mal deutlich gemacht, da gibt es auch Geschichten aus der Vergangenheit, wenn du im Training nicht Gas gibst und dann kommt Zlatan und spricht dich an, sorry, ich tue jetzt so, als würde ich ihn persönlich kennen, es ist logischerweise Herr Imbrimovic, nichts Zlatan für mich, dann macht das was mit dir, wenn der sagt, hey Junge, wir sind hier bei Milan, es geht nicht, dass wir hier nur so ein bisschen Larifari machen, ich brauche Einsatz, vollsten Einsatz und das hat man jetzt wirklich in diesen ersten Spielen ein bisschen gemerkt, er wirkt einfach so als Schutzschild, glaube ich auch für viele, da gibt logisch viel Fokus auf ihn und die Mannschaft hat wirklich etwas befreit, ein bisschen selbstsicherer gewirkt.
Das ist ja verrückt, das hätte ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht gedacht, gar nicht erwartet, aber das sieht man mal, es gibt nicht immer nur sportliche Argumente für Transfer. Jetzt sind neulich an mir die Geschäftszahlen von Milan vorbeigeflogen auf Twitter. Da müssen wir einen Wirtschaftspodcast machen. Ich fasse es einfach kurz, sehr viel Rot war dabei, den Zahlen mit dabei und das sieht einfach, also wirtschaftlich, das haben wir ja hier auch schon mal thematisiert und ich glaube, ich glaube in allerersten Serie A Kurzpass haben wir auch schon mal über die chinesischen Eigentümer gesprochen und so weiter, aber das ist ja eine Komponente, da habe ich das Gefühl, davon kann man Milan nicht mehr trennen, von diesem Schuldenberg, also du hast gerade gesagt, die Erwartungen sind hoch und da habe ich mir gleich gedacht, ja die Schulden halt auch. Gibt es da Bewegung? Wird sich das irgendwie verändern mittelfristig?
Gute Frage. Also ich glaube, das Einzige Gute momentan ist, wenn man sich auch so ein bisschen den Kader anschaut, es gibt jetzt mittlerweile ein paar Spieler und das hätte man vor ein paar Monaten, muss man fairerweise sagen, auch noch nicht so gehabt. Du hast so ein paar Spieler, wo wirklich wieder so ein bisschen auch, ja ein bisschen, sage ich mal, monetäres Potenzial leistet, zum Beispiel Theo Hernández, den Bruder von Bayern Hernández, der wirklich als Außenverteidiger eine brutal starke Saison macht, hat jetzt ein bisschen das, was Goossens macht, macht er bei Milan auch schon fünf Tore, brutal offensiv stark geht vorne mit rein. Du hast Ismael Benazer, den hat man glaube ich damals noch nicht angesprochen, der war zum Spieler des Afrika Cups gewesen. Ein ganz junger Mann, der hat am Anfang ein bisschen im Zentrum seine Anlaufschwierigkeiten gehabt und jetzt ist er da wirklich fest installiert, macht das sehr gut. Das ist auch einer, an dem kannst du dich aufbauen. Donnarumma war in den letzten Spielen herausragend, hat Milan mehrmals wieder eine Sieg gerettet. Auch jetzt am Wochenende in Brescia hätten sie eigentlich nicht gewinnen dürfen, gewinnen sie aber, weil Donnarumma hinten zu macht. Du hast so ein bisschen, du hast mit Léo, den jungen Sturmpartner von Ibrahimovic, du hast schon auch wieder so ein bisschen personelle Hoffnung da, dass man das Ganze vielleicht auch mal monetär dann wieder vielleicht auch ein bisschen in die Richtung lenken kann. Und du hast Ante Rebic, der die letzten zwei Spiele für mich dann entschieden hat.
Ja, da habe ich einige Frankfurt-Freunde, die haben das gar nicht so gerne.
Ich weiß, die haben sich ganz sicher nicht darüber gefreut. Klar, der war ja wirklich, muss man auch sagen, bis vor den zwei Spielen völlig vom Radar, hat keine Rolle gespielt. Und dann kommt er plötzlich rein, entscheidet das Udinnesspiel und macht auch jetzt am Wochenende das 1-0 in Brescia. Also ich glaube nicht, dass du den jetzt noch im Winter von Mailand wegkriegst.
Dieser Zug ist abgefahren, vor allem, weil man ja auch sieht, was derjenige, der für ihn nach Frankfurt gekommen ist, gerade so zum leisten im Stande ist, André Silva. Okay, das sind jetzt die Plätze 1 bis 8 gewesen. Wir haben auch schon über Napoli auf Platz 10 gesprochen. Gibt es denn noch andere interessante Geschichten, wo du sagst, darüber müssen wir sprechen?
Nur, ich würde vielleicht kurz die Fiorentina noch ansprechen, weil die auch, die steht momentan auf Platz 13. Das schaut jetzt nicht sehr prickelnd aus, aber die hat sich auch gefangen in den letzten Wochen. Die Fiorentina hat auch den Trainer gewechselt, da musste ja Montella gehen. Dann kam Jakine, das ist so ein ehrlicher, ja vielleicht kann man ein bisschen mit Friedhelm Funkel vergleichen. Also nur um eine Idee zu haben, das ist ein ehrlicher Arbeiter, der sagt auch bei der seiner ersten BKR, hey Jungs, mach's langsam, ich bin kein Sauberer. Wir werden hier einfach viel arbeiten und dann schauen wir, dass wir das gemeinsam hinkriegen. Und hat glaube ich auch dieser Tage erzählt, weil viel über Technik und Handy ging, hat er glaube ich erzählt, dass er ein 35-Euro-Handybesitzer ist. Also das ist einer…
Das ist der neue Trainer von Franck Ribery.
Ja da ist, also da ist Glamour-Faktor genau Null, aber halt harte, ehrliche Arbeit und die Fiorentiner hat sich wirklich unter ihm jetzt da rausgezogen, hat eben letzte Woche in Neapel gewonnen, hat auch davor zweimal gewonnen, hat Atalanta aus dem Pokal rausgenommen und ist schön zu sehen, finde ich. Man redet ja immer viel, gerade medial hat man immer diese Glamour-Leute oder Leute, die halt irgendwie ja scheinen und das ist einer, der genauer Gegenteil ist, aber einfach der der Fiorentiner, die definitiv Potenzial hatte ja schon personell, weil er jetzt irgendwie einfach mal ein bisschen Struktur gegeben hat und ich bin sehr gespannt, denn nächstes Wochenende ist Juve, kommt die Fiorentiner nach Turin und Juve ist der große Dauerrivale von Florenz, also ist für die auch ein ganz besonderes Spiel und ich traue denen einiges zu, weil sie auch in Neapel das ganze, ja Napoli sehr abgekocht haben und viele interessante Leute auch da, haben jetzt wahrscheinlich die Zeit dafür, aber um einen zu nennen, ich weiß nicht, haben wir Gaetano Castorvidi schon mal angesprochen? Junger Italiener, der war letztes Jahr noch in die Serie B ausgeliehen und das ist wirklich auch so ein moderner Mittelfeldspieler, ich bin mir auch relativ sicher, dass wir den bei der EM sehen werden oder zumindest im Kader. Das ist wirklich, das macht eine Freude, dem Jungen zuzuschauen, der ist extrem laufstark, technisch stark, geht in die meisten Triplings der ganzen Liga, also der hat keine Angst davor, das ganze spielerisch zu lösen, eine riesen Spielfreude, also wenn du den siehst, denkst du dir, ok, alles klar, deswegen sind Fußballer halt oft während sie Profi, weil sie einfach gerne kicken und definitiv der Aufsteiger der Saison, nicht nur bei der Fiorentina, sondern einer, der wirklich vor Spielfreude strahlt und das Ganze wirklich sehr positiv angeht. Ein sehr interessanter junger Mann.
Wahnsinn. Also es gibt sogar einen Spieler, der noch häufiger ins Tripling geht, das ist Jiméry Boga von Sassolo.
Genau, aber wie gesagt, der ist weit vorne dabei, ist anscheinend auch schon relativ eng mit Ribéry. Er hat auch gesagt, dass die im Training oft, dass er da auch bei Ribéry oft schon am Anfang der Saison als Ribéry noch gesund war, sich immer wieder ein bisschen was abgeschaut hat. Ja, es geht wirklich in die Richtung. Das ist einer, der sehr viel Selbstvertrauen hat, das merkst du dem auch gleich an, so von der Körperhaltung, aber wirklich sehr spannende Personalie.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Und Franck Ribéry in dieser liegweiten Wertung ja auch auf Platz 4 jetzt nicht so schlecht. Die Fiorentiner, der wird ganz gerne erfolgreich.
Ja, kommt ja noch hoffentlich irgendwann in den nächsten Wochen zurück. Also ich glaube, das soll sich schon noch ein bisschen hinziehen. Die Fiorentiner hat jetzt auch Kutrone zurückgeholt aus England, auch ganz interessanter junger Stürmer vorne drin, galt ja vor ein, zwei Jahren als der neue Insagi auch zukünftig so Richtung Nationalmannschaft. Chiesa ist sowieso da. Also die Fiorentiner ist jetzt gefestigt und ist eine Mannschaft, die, glaube ich, definitiv eher auf dem Weg nach oben ist. Stark.
Und dann sehe ich einen sehr, sehr spannenden Tabellenkeller. Da liegen vier Vereine im Abstand von zwei Punkten. Lecce mit 16 Punkten und dann Spall, Genua und Brescia alle mit 15 Punkten. Sieht jetzt auch nicht so unspannend aus da unten.
Alles andere als unspannend und was auch, finde ich, vielleicht auch ein bisschen untypisch für einen Abstiegskampf ist. Gerade Lecce und Brescia sind Mannschaften, die spielen. Also das ist jetzt nicht so dieses klassische, okay, ich stelle mich hinten rein und schaue halt irgendwie mal bei den Großen, wie ein Punkt zur Gattern und dann irgendwie daheim halt gegen meine direkten Konkurrenten zu gewinnen. Lecce spielt eigentlich einen feinen Ball, hat eben auch, hat Inter zuletzt auch gestoppt im heimischen Stadion unentschieden, abgeluchst. Brescia jetzt am Wochenende gegen Milan. Und wie gesagt, Milan darf dieses Spiel eigentlich nicht gewinnen, weil Brescia war wirklich am Zug Tonali immer noch grandios, also was Tonali Woche für Woche bringt, der Junge da im zentralen Mittelfeld. Also wirklich großes Kino. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was da im Sommer passiert. Da sind ja alle dran. Juve heißt jetzt, dass sie wieder ganz, ganz nachhaltig…
Aber Juve kann sich doch nicht jeden holen.
Ja gut, aber junge Italiener, das ist halt auch… Und ich glaube wirklich, dass Zornali das Potenzial hat, sofort auf Anhieb auch bei einer Klassemannschaft zumindest eine gute Rolle einzunehmen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob der da sofort hinkommt und jedes Spiel macht. Aber der zeigt so einen Reifegrad, auch jetzt gegen Milan wieder. Ich habe es ein bisschen gesehen, dass es wirklich diese Ruhe, diese Übersicht, dieses Stellungsspiel auch gut gegen den Ball. Da reden wir nicht nur über feine Bässe nach vorne, sondern… Und ich glaube, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, er ist immer noch 19. Oder maximal 20. Also das ist wirklich Tonali ganz, ganz viele Daumen nach oben, sozusagen. Und deswegen auch schade, dass Brescia, bei Brescia habe ich oft das Gefühl, die würden so viel mehr sich verdienen, aber gehen dann oft mit einem 0-0-0 raus oder am Ende verlieren sie, so wie jetzt gegen Milan. Aber spielerisch ist da definitiv das Potenzial da.
Also 19 ist er noch. Sandro Tonali. Eigentlich wären wir jetzt durch, aber ich gönne uns jetzt noch fünf extra Minuten, denn ich habe das Gefühl, wir werden da definitiv nochmal ausführlicher darüber sprechen müssen. Aber könnte es sein, dass Italien eine Bomben-EM spielt? Das hört sich so an, als ob da sehr, sehr viele junge Spieler nachdrücken.
Das ist definitiv so. Also Italien hat, wir haben jetzt ein paar schon genannt, diese Generationen im Pellegrini, Castrovilli, das sind auch so Spielertypen, Senzi von Inter, die hatte Italien lang nicht mehr. Also ich glaube wirklich, da merkt man, dass in den letzten Jahren gut gearbeitet wurde, da kommt vieles nach. Ich sage es so, Mancini hat schon eine richtig gute Arbeit gemacht, der hat einen Stil in seiner Nationalmannschaft geändert, wirklich innerhalb von eineinhalb Jahren ist das jetzt eine Mannschaft, die spielen will, die den Ball fordert, du hast Verratti eben im Zentrum, Verratti, Giorginho, eventuell noch Senzi dazu, das sind alles Jungs, die wollen spielen, da ist nichts mehr, oh wir sind das Abwarten in Italien, macht ihr mal, wir machen hinten gut zu und dann passiert schon was. Das ist wirklich, also es ist eine fußballerische Kulturrevolution, die da Mancini wirklich, muss man wirklich so sagen, vorangetrieben hat und definitiv auch auf den Weg gebracht hat. Das Entscheidende wird jetzt logischerweise sein, es gab noch nicht diesen großen, sage ich mal, Pflichtspiel, klar, Quali, ja, aber es gab noch nicht das große Turnier. So, ich glaube, dass die Italiener, wenn sie es schaffen, sie haben diese neuen Möglichkeiten, spielerisch auch. Wie gesagt, du kannst im Mittelfall tonal auch, du hast da plötzlich sieben, acht Leute, wo ich sagen würde, die kannst du alle reinstellen, da würde ich mir jetzt so vom Namen her wenig Sorgen machen. Ich glaube, das entscheide wird sein, wenn sie diese neu gewonnene spielerische Leichtigkeit und spielerische Freude, wenn sie es schaffen, das zu kombinieren mit den Faktoren, die Italien immer stark gemacht hat, sprich diese taktische Variabilität und auch dieses emotionale, italienische Mannschaft, wenn es eine WM war, da wusste jeder Gegner, ich will nicht gegen Italien spielen. Da ging es auch nicht darum, Italien hatte selten die besten Einzelspieler. Italien hatte auch 2.6 mit Abstand nicht die besten Einzelspieler, aber die hatten eine sehr gute Haltung. Genau, eine Haltung, eine Seele auch. Die schaffen es dann oft irgendwie für die paar Wochen, so ein Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl zu kreieren. Und wenn er das schafft, Manncini, also klar, wie gesagt, auf dem Papier sind andere Mannschaften noch vorne, keine Frage. Aber wenn er schafft, eben diese alten, sage ich mal, italienischen Tugend ein bisschen zu würzen, mit diesem zu mischen, mit diesem spielerischen neuen Element, dann glaube ich, ist einiges möglich.
Ach, Wahnsinn, weißt du, ich gucke echt gerade nicht mit Vorfreude auf die EM, weil direkt nach dem Royale muss ich mit der EM-Vorschau beginnen und dann werden es wieder tägliche Sendungen. Das wird zwar alles Spaß machen, aber es wird unglücklich anstrengend. Aber ja, wenn ich mit dir spreche, dann freue ich mich auf einmal auch auf die EM.
Ich freue mich auch auf die Sendungen, meint ich. Also da gibt es dann wieder sehr viel zu besprechen und das wird sicher spannend.
Ja, vor allem man lernt halt auch tatsächlich so viel. Wir Deutschen leben schon in einer fußballerischen Blase, also man muss dankbar sein, wenn mal in öffentlich-rechtlichen irgendeinem Premier League oder La Liga-Spiel gezeigt wird. Aber das sind auch immer dieselben drei, die man da sieht. Und da geht halt einfach gerade viel verloren. Und während halt die Bundesliga die torreichste Liga der Europas aktuell ist und auch kein schlechter Fußball drin gespielt wird, habe ich trotzdem das Gefühl, dass sich andere Ligen gerade weiterentwickeln. Und da gehört auf jeden Fall die Serie A mit dazu.
Es gibt wirklich, wie gesagt, allein das – schön, dass wir das jetzt auch am Ende noch mal kurz thematisiert haben – diese neuen Spieler-Typen. Das wäre, glaube ich, vor drei, vier Jahren undenkbar gewesen. Du hattest immer diese selben Typen, dann hattest du dieses taktische Korsett, das logisch immer, glaube ich, bei Italienern sehr, sehr gut war. Aber jetzt hast du halt auch so ein bisschen Pfiff. Deswegen haben wir auch Castrovilli angesprochen. Das ist wirklich so was, das kannte man eigentlich vor ein paar Jahren nicht. Das ist wirklich, den schaust du dir an und denkst so, ach cool, der will kicken. Und der kann kicken und der weiß, was er zu tun hat. Und der macht das aber nicht hier so, hier nur tralala, Ball zurückziehen, sondern der arbeitet auch nach hinten, der ist läuferisch aktiv. Also das ist wirklich ein neues Element. Und wie gesagt, ich bin sehr gespannt, wenn Lazio Immobile dann auch ein bisschen Eingang in die Nationalmannschaft findet.
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, zieh dich warm an, Europa.
Wir brauchen es jetzt nicht zu groß. Darum geht es jetzt nicht.
Es geht darum, das sind acht Spiele bis zum Titel oder sieben Spiele, weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht. Da kommen ganz viele Faktoren mit rein. Aber Italien hat eine Historie aus, böse gesagt, aus wenig viel zu machen. Und jetzt hört sich das so an, als hätte man diesmal nicht mal wenig.
Genau, als wäre ein bisschen mehr dabei. Das hast du sehr schön auf den Punkt gebracht, das finde ich ja. Und wenn sie das schaffen, miteinander zu vermengen, nicht nur das eine zurücklassen, dann ist das, was wir vorhin auch schon gesagt haben, dass glaube ich wenige gern gegen Italien spielen, wird dann sicher wieder der Fall sein. Und vielleicht hat dann Italien sogar dieses Quentchen fußballerischer Klasse mehr, das ihnen vielleicht in den Jahren davor gefehlt hat.
Und man hat ja auch Spiele in Rom, es ist ja ähnlich wie mit Deutschland.
Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, ist es sogar das Eröffnungsspiel gegen die Türkei.
Ist es, hast du recht.
Und um da den Kreis zu schließen, da hatten wir leider auch kurz vor Kurzem, es gab dieses Juve-Roma-Spiel, wo es sich in einem Spiel, Sanjolo von der Roma, der auch einer dieser Jungs gewesen wäre, die da wahrscheinlich für Vorräte gesorgt haben, und Demiral, der Juvenen-Verteidiger, der ja wirklich auf dem Weg war, jetzt auch bei Juve in eine zentrale Rolle, wo sich beide das Kreuzband gerissen haben und die wären wahrscheinlich da sechs Monate später genau am selben Platz, am selben Feld beim Eröffnungsspiel sich gegenüber gestanden.
Ach, der Fußball. Christian, ich könnte, ach, es macht immer so viel Spaß, allein, allein für diesen Kurzpass hat es sich gelohnt, die Kurzpass-Faße wieder aufzuheben. Ich danke dir sehr, man kann dich hören auf TheZone, da bist du immer wieder als Experte für Spiele mit dabei und ich denke, wir alle haben gehört, warum. Ich danke dir, Christian, dass du dir immer wieder die Zeit genommen hast.
Ja, vielen Dank, Max, hat großen Spaß gemacht.
Und danke euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ihr könnt, wenn ihr den Rasenfunk unterstützen wollt, euch unter eindecken unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de. Du kriegst gleich auch noch eine Tasse von mir. Und ihr könnt uns natürlich auch direkt finanziell unterstützen auf rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Den nächsten Kurzpass gibt's ja nächste Woche und dann wird's um die 2. Liga gehen. Endlich auch mal wieder. Macht's gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.